pardon madame est ce que vous auriez dit
francs pour payer le café quoi pardon
monsieur est ce que vous auriez s'il
vous plaît de 10 francs pour régler mon
café vous allez auriez vous s'il vous
plaît la modique somme de 10 francs
enfants que je m'acquitte cette
excitante l'ibal vous avez sap à nice où
un bal qu'on paye et le café
je tenais vraiment c'est pas une bonne
idée de me reprendre la capture gens
méritent
oui mais pas dans la mesure où ouais
mais c'est moins prestigieux puis à
moins de blaireaux pour payer la moitié
ailleurs ya six mois vous avez
d'éteindre les tickets de métro j'ai du
courrier à faire et je dois faire des
choix on abuse et pas mal hein alors bon
d'accord merci maman donnez moi au moins
dix balles bah évidemment je suis gonflé
mais gagner plein de pognon êtes paco
rabanne ou vous êtes bourrés doublé
alors vous n'allez pas chez un peu de
pognon
morin balle en retrait je n'ai pas
poindre une capuche et un beau petit cd
voix drake a pris 1,51 blaireau pour le
payer merci monsieur à merci excusez moi
je me suis trompé ses 23 ans excusez moi
autant pour moi à lancieux partez pas
sans payer vous venez de l'état 20
points gap et zombies
vietnam haut niveau et que clébard la
france soyez sympa de l'émoi 10 francs
dépanner mois et coûté très franchement
c'est la première fois je vous demande
quelque chose
ok je vous ai jamais rien demandé avant
mais moi je vous ai jamais rien demandé
avant alors pour une fois pour une fois
je vous demande un service vous êtes
vraiment pas sympa à mon avis est plein
d'objets des débits journaux on vous
attend séché d'abord bon écoutez j'ai
pas le temps payé mon café qu'on en
finisse
c'est plein de blé c'est une double et
vous auriez simplement différent pour la
gueule tapée il me manque des fonds
merci vous êtes bien gentil monsieur
aujourd'hui à peine étonné je vois vous
allez entendre la volée mettez le tout
payé tout ça m'arrange deux postes
différents
merci messieurs
ah si
tu as bien gentil monsieur merci je vais
régler comme ça merci monsieur
non
non non c'est ce qu'a fait monsieur
merci bonne bourre pardon vous montrer
le cap et c'est très sympa gentil à vous
je vous remercie infiniment mieux êtes
content si tout le monde était comme
vous monsieur en toi même et c'est tout
le monde était comme merci monsieur
télémaque nova qui va régler mon café et
a bon coeur toi y en a pour vingt balles
matt a bon coeur
bt que j'ai il manque 10 balles vous met
dix bals max tales of war est mince mais
mieux mais les [ __ ]